okay so you want to get AWS certified
but everyone keeps telling you something
different go for this sot wait no this
one's better seriously it can feel like
navigating a forest with a blindfold on
I know just how confusing it could be to
figure out where to start and so in this
video I'll be sharing with you the best
AWS certification learning paths as
recommended by AWS themselves before we
get started if you're someone learning
cloud and want to level up your Tech
skills make sure you subscribe to this
channel because I make weekly videos to
help you navigate your Learning Journey
all right let's get into it so so this
is the PDF guide that AWS has created
that outlines all the different learning
paths available depending on the role
that you're interested in AWS recommends
a set of certifications for that
position you can see here that there's
Solutions architect application
architect cloud data engineer and so on
I'll leave a link to this document down
in the description below so that you can
save a copy for yourself but today I'm
going to go through some of these roles
explain the different certification
Pathways and share with you my own
thoughts and opinions on which
certifications you should aim for okay
first things first where is the best
place to start well if you're someone
new to Tech either from a non-it
background or switching into a cloud
career AWS recommends starting off with
the cloud practitioner certification
this is a foundational level exam that
focuses on the basic Cloud Concepts and
terminology once you complete this
certification you'll be able to look at
entry-level Cloud jobs and also consider
earning additional certifications now if
you're in a business role for example
sales and marketing AWS also recommends
starting off with the cloud practitioner
so in this case the goal of the
certification is to help you communicate
better with customers and stakeholders
who are also using the cloud for example
if I'm a salesperson and I want to sell
you some AWS Services I would at least
have to know what these services are and
how they can help you however if you're
someone who already has 1 to 3 years of
experience in it and stem instead of
starting off with the cloud practitioner
exam ads recommends getting an associate
level certification that aligns with
your role and interests so for instance
if I want to become a Solutions
architect I would get the associate
Solutions architect certification the
goal goal here is not only to validate
your Knowledge and Skills in AWS but
also help you gain the confidence and
credibility that you need in order to
build a successful Cloud career speaking
of careers in the cloud there are 13
roles that AWS has created learning
paths for there's Solutions architect
application architect cloud data
engineer software development engineer
systems administrator Cloud engineer
test engineer Cloud devops engineer Dev
seops engineer Cloud security engineer
Cloud security architect network
engineer and finally machine learning
engineer
okay I know I've just read out a whole
bunch of roles but the good news is you
really only need to aim for one of them
I have a video on my channel sharing the
top five in demand Cloud careers so make
sure you check it out if you're
interested however I would also
recommend doing your own research to try
and figure out which role is right for
you what I'm going to do now is go
through three of my favorite roles on
the list and then you can read through
the rest yourself after this video so
the first one is a Solutions architect
according to this document a Solutions
architect is someone who's responsible
for designing developing and managing
Cloud infrastructure they also work with
devops to migrate applications to the
cloud this is the role I was in when I
worked at AWS and I can definitely say
that this certification pathway is
pretty spot- on so starting off with a
cloud practitioner then Solutions Artic
associate Solutions Arctic professional
and then getting the security specialty
certification however my own
certification path was a little bit
different instead of going straight to
the solutions Arctic professional after
just getting one associate set I decided
to complete the other two associate
exams as well these were the associate
developer certification and the
associate ssop certification there's
nothing wrong with following the direct
path on the screen but personally for me
I found that doing more associate level
certifications helped me gain more
confidence so that it was easier for me
to tackle the professional one so if you
want to take a one step at a time it
might be helpful for you to do a few
associate certifications before jumping
into the professional search another one
of my favorite roles is the cloud
engineer a cloud engineer's main job is
to handle the design deployment and
operation of large scale cloud computing
environments they also advocate for
endtoend automated cicd devops pipelines
I really like this role because Cloud
Engineers are pretty much the backbone
of any major Cloud operation they're the
ones making sure that everything is set
up properly and working as it should be
now if you're looking to become a cloud
engineer you'd want to look into getting
the cloud practitioner certification
followed by the ssops administrator
certification this is because the sis
oper Dives deep into deploying operating
and managing systems on AWS after
completing that AWS recommends going for
the security specialty exam this
certification focuses on advanced
concepts such as identity management
data encryption and incident response
three very important topics to know
about as a cloud engineer and once
you've gotten all the certifications
I've just mentioned there are two more
certifications that AWS recommends for
this role so the devops engineer
professional and the advanced networking
specialty but in my honest opinion these
are optional especially if you're
looking for your very first job in the
cloud as think at this point it would
usually be better for you to focus on
building Hands-On projects and gaining
some real world experience rather than
just sitting more exams the third role I
wanted to highlight is the machine
learning engineer machine learning
Engineers are people who research build
and design AI systems their goal is to
automate predictive models and work on
machine learning projects in their
company the reason I wanted to highlight
this role is because demand in this
field is skyrocketing not just because
of all the hype with chat gbt but
because more and more companies are
looking to integrate Ai and machine
learning into their operations to build
the skills needed to become a machine
learning engineer AWS recommends
starting off with the cloud practitioner
certification and then doing a few
associate level certifications before
jumping into the machine learning
specialty so I think the main reason
they don't want you to dive straight
into the machine learning certification
is because you'll need to have a solid
understanding of the core AWS services
and Concepts before jumping into
something more complex like machine
learning all right before we continue
I'd like to share with you a fantastic
learning platform called skillshare
skillshare is an online online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for anyone who loves learning
and wants to explore their creativity
and learn new skills if you have
specific skills you're trying to learn
skillshare is a great place to start
they have courses ranging from Tech and
finance to productivity video editing
and more if you're a beginner interested
in learning more about the cloud I'd
recommend enrolling In This Cloud
Computing for business people course I
joined skillshare to learn more about
tech and productivity and by taking
classes like these I hope to continue
building my skills the first 1,000
people to use the link in the
description below will'll get a free
one- month trial of skillshare so if
you'd like to learn new skills I'd
highly recommend signing up to
skillshare for one month of free access
thank you skillshare for sponsoring this
video if you've gotten up to this point
I want to thank you for sticking around
comment below with the phrase let's
learn Cloud just so I know who watched
this video all the way to the end but
before you go I want to leave you with
some of my final thoughts on these
certification paths firstly this whole
video is just a guide AWS has outlined
some pretty solid Pathways in the
document but remember that everyone
journey is unique so feel free to adapt
the road map into whatever makes the
most sense for you secondly make sure
you set a study plan I know sometimes
watching YouTube videos like this one
can make you feel productive but make
sure you also block out time each week
to do some deep focus work for example
setting aside 3 hours each weekend to
study for an AWS certification and
finally I want to emphasize that
certifications are not everything they
can help you open up new doors and new
job opportunities but there are also
other things you need to consider like
building Hands-On projects and
developing your soft skills if you'd
like to learn more about what to do
after getting an ads certification make
sure you check out this video over here
thanks everyone again for watching and
I'll see you soon bye for
now